our track browser mode generates levels  on the fly at the press of one button  it's random so we have no idea what  we're going to drive three steps to it  terraforming look at the pretty beaches  and islands then the track being built  and finally signage infinite tracks you  can immediately play let's see how well  you do false well it'd be careful it's  tricky easier to win an Academy Award  than playing live 83 hand yeah funny  restocked is immediate go  by the way this is a completely new  environment especially made for  TrackMania turbo it's called roller  coaster Lagoon we also have a brand new  take on multiplayer roads but for that  come be times on the arcade machines on  the booth and if you're crazy enough  come play the VR demo at the show thank  you I'll get to Deemas danke Schon  shochet gracias Nancy spasiba